[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
- El Salvador,
Guatemala, and Honduras
are some of our
closest neighbors.
Yet, many North
Americans don't know
that this region is experiencing
some of the highest levels
of violence in the world.
Families caught in the
middle of this violence
have few options for
protection or assistance.
As a result, many people
are left with no choice
but to migrate across
international borders.
Cristosal is a human
rights organization
based in El Salvador working
to strengthen assistance
and protection options
for victims of violence
in the region, to write-based
programming, research,
and learning.
One case at a time, we come
alongside victims of violence
to provide protection
when they need it most.
And repair the lingering effects
of violations they suffer.
One community at
a time, we worked
to build human
rights' environments
and create conditions where
peace building is possible.
- We started by
taking just one case.
That case, and each new case we
commit to, has a ripple effect.
When we say human
rights matter, we
mean for all people
in all places.
We're fundamentally concerned
about our brothers and sisters
independently of what
country they live in
because we know ultimately
that how they're treated
will affect peace and
security for all of us.
- [SPEAKING SPANISH]
- Our Center for Research
and Learning grounds its work
in community perspectives.
We work with vulnerable groups
to research the discrimination,
violence, and human rights
violations that affect them.
One group at a time,
we're empowering people
with the knowledge to
defend human rights.
- With each case, we
protect the individual lives
of people at risk.
We reject historic
cultures of impunity.
We build human
rights environments
and we send a
message to the world
about the value of individual
human life and dignity.
- One group at a time.
- [SPEAKING SPANISH]
- One case at a time, we're
advancing human rights
in Central America.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
NOAH BULLOCK: Thank you again,
John, for the invitation to be
here with you all.
And thanks for making time
in your busy schedules.
We know how important
your work is as well.
It's an honor to be
able to share what we do
and to know that there
are people interested here
in Palo Alto and Google.
So thank you, again,
for sharing with me.
I thought I'd start
a little bit talking
about the region itself.
Central America
is a place that's
geographically close to
us, as Kathy mentioned.
Who doesn't know
a Central America?
They're our neighbors.
They live among us.
They are some of us.
But also, our
countries and regions
have been interconnected
politically,
interconnected in
business relationships.
It's a region of
the world that I
think a lot of North
Americans don't
think a lot about unless
there's a negative headline
in the newspaper.
And one of the reasons,
or one of the ways
that North Americans have
become more familiar or aware
of Central America,
is through migrants.
And more specifically,
through children.
Central American children who in
2014 surprised our government,
or country, because they
came in the tens of thousands
unaccompanied to
our southern border.
And then more
recently, the situation
of children being separated.
Migrant children from Central
America being separated
from their families I think
shook the country again
and made us confront difficult
moral and ethical questions
about the way we treat people,
our neighbors who come mostly
looking for protection
in our country.
And I think that's what I
wanted to talk more about.
The issue of immigration is
obviously a polemic issue.
But I think there's
an important statistic
that we should
remember when we're
trying to interpret what it
means in our country right now.
Immigration is in the
top 10, if not five,
political issues of the day.
Yet strikingly, the
numbers of immigrants
coming into our country
is at a 30-year low.
So it's important
to reflect on what
is the nature of
migration crisis,
if it is that we have one here.
And I think it's also important
to put it in context to what's
happening globally.
There are more people in the
world displaced by violence
than even during World War II,
which was the previous record.
So there is a significant
crisis globally
in people fleeing their homes.
Protection of crisis,
because oftentimes
they flee their homes they
aren't finding the solutions
that they're looking for.
But in our country,
we can't say that we
have that problem of numbers.
We can't say that our
communities are being inundated
by a wave of migration.
Because statistically
that's not happening.
If we do have a
crisis in our country,
I would say it's a
crisis of response.
What's changed about immigration
from Central America and Mexico
to the United States
is the demographic.
What we have now
is less the profile
of an individual coming from
Central America or Mexico
looking for a job
or temporary work.
And now we're having to
deal with the arrival
of entire families, mostly
from Central America,
coming to the United States.
And many of them
are fleeing directly
threats of violence
and persecution,
or indirectly struggling to
live in an environment of what
we call generalized violence.
And so that demographic
shift in immigration
has been a significant
challenge because it
raises important questions
about our responsibilities,
or our government's
responsibilities,
to these people who arrive.
Have they arrived illegally?
Are they criminals?
How should we respond?
And I think that's
one of the things that
made the policy of separating
children from their family so
shocking to many people.
Because I think that
there's increasing awareness
among people in
the United States
that children aren't
here to steal our jobs
or to cause problems
in our communities.
Something is going
on in the region
in Central America that's
moving entire families to uproot
themselves at great risk
to themselves to cross
a border with little expectation
that they would be received
and given legal status.
Something must be
compelling them to flee.
And I want to talk a little bit
more about those conditions.
This idea of the prospect of a
demographic shift of migrants
means that we have to challenge
our traditional narrative
about immigration in the
Mesoamerican migratory
corridor.
We've thought for decades
now that the primary profile
of a migrant moving through
Mexico into the United States
is an economic migrant.
One looking for opportunity.
And that's the nature
of what a migrant is.
It's someone who's chosen to
leave their homes in search
of a better opportunity or
other options, education,
family unification.
But when people are compelled
to flee, they act differently.
Often times people
who are forced to flee
don't even have a
destination necessarily.
They're not moving
with a specific plan
that they thought out.
They're moving because they
were forced from their homes
and are desperately
trying to find an option.
And that's different
than when people
are trying to look for
a better opportunity
and having planned or chosen
to take on their immigration.
And so in Central
America our work
has focused primarily on
people who are internally
displaced by violence.
Meaning that one
of the patterns we
see that's related
to migratory outflows
or transnational
movements of people
is that people who
are fleeing oftentimes
use internal displacement
as a precursor
to a transnational
migratory route.
For example, the first step may
often be moving from one home
to another.
Or staying with a family
member in the country of origin
as a first means of
trying to find protection.
And when those people exhaust
the options for protection,
even using family
resources or even at times
trying to get the
state to assist them,
then they make the
decision to cross a border.
And that moment is
really important.
Because when people
are still within
their national boundaries
of the country of origin,
the international
frameworks tell us
that internally
displaced people are
the primary responsibilities
of the state
and the government of
the country of origin.
But when they cross an
international border, when
a person-- this is the language
of the Refugee Convention--
is unable or unwilling
to avail themselves
of the protection in
their country of origin,
that responsibility to
protect is transferred
onto the host country.
And the idea is
that no human being
can be denied a
place on planet Earth
where they can live free from
persecution and violence.
It's to say that
everyone should be
able to find some
place on planet Earth
where their rights and basic
protection can be guaranteed.
And so when Central
Americans make that decision
to cross an
international border,
they aren't being often
recognized as refugees.
They're being treated as
illegal or regular migrants.
And that's a
problematic scenario
because you have
tens of thousands
of people moving across
borders seeking protection.
And no state is able
to give it to them.
It's almost like forcing
a group of people
to live in the shadows.
I call it one of the greatest
acts of privatization
in our generation,
is the privatization
of the responsibility
to protect,
which is primarily among
states but has been privatized
to the families.
And families do
courageous and often crazy
things to try and find ways to
get their members to safety.
And when North Americans
ask, for example,
how is it possible that
Central American parents send
their children on a
company to our border?
It's because they're
making those very difficult
calculations about how they can
find safety for at least one
of their members.
And knowing that
the United States
has made great efforts to deter
migration by using detention.
Or cruel conditions
while in detention
to send messages back to
Central American families
about how they will
be received when
they come to the United States.
That doesn't deter
a family who's
faced with death, torture, rape,
or persecution in their homes.
And so in some ways
these strategies
that are abusive to migrants
in our own countries
are also failures
on a policy level
because they fail to understand
what it means to flee and not
just migrate for opportunities.
Cristosal-- our work as a human
rights organization focuses,
as you heard in the
video, on accompanying
victims of violence.
We're not necessarily
working on migration.
We see migration
and displacement
as a consequence of
failure to protect rights
and of a situation of
generalized violence
in the region.
And just to give
you a sense of what
I mean by that,
between 2005 and 2009
El Salvador, for
example, per capita
had a higher rate of
violent death than Iraq
during the peak of
their armed conflict.
There was an interesting
academic article written
by a colleague who wrote--
the title of his piece was "More
Deadly Than Armed Conflict."
And he looked at homicide
rates in the Northern Triangle,
El Salvador, Guatemala,
and Honduras,
and compared those to combined
homicide and casualty rates
in countries like Syria or Iraq
that have open-armed conflicts,
more traditional
armed conflicts.
And the outcome of
that analysis is
that these are some of
the most violent countries
in the world even taking into
account countries in open war.
And so what you
have in El Salvador
is a situation that isn't
necessarily a traditional war,
but one that's generating
humanitarian consequences that
are comparative to other
armed conflicts in the world.
And that's something
that has been difficult
not only to integrate into this
narrative about immigration.
Then perhaps we have
a refugee crisis
on the American continent.
But it's been
difficult to integrate
into the security approaches in
the countries of the Northern
Triangle.
And what the governments have
done in response to violence
is to declare war on
criminal groups that
are the primary perpetrators
of atrocities and acts
of violence, so street gangs.
Street gangs is a diminutive
way of talking about them
because they have
capacities that generally
go beyond what we understand
in the United States
as a street gang.
They control territories.
They control many aspects
of the lives of the people
who live in those territories,
like where they can work.
How they can sell if
they have a store.
Where they can go to school.
Where you can get health care.
We've seen cases
where grandchildren
have gone to visit
their grandmothers
and had to cross an invisible
boundary between one gang
territory and the other.
And that has led to violent
acts perpetrated against them
in reprisals for having entered
into opposite gang territory
even though those people
aren't members of the gang.
The easiest way to understand
it is to compare it
to the way dictators work.
Dictators control countries.
They control many aspects
of the lives of the people.
And people try and
find ways to live
within those countries
acquiescent often
to criminal actions of the state
up until they can't, the point
where they can't anymore.
Let's say in Syria, well,
I no longer can do this.
Maybe I'm going to protest.
And as soon as you challenge the
authority of the dictatorship,
the dictatorship responds
with persecution and violence
against you the same way that
the gangs act in communities.
Gangs will force community
member for pay extortion.
They'll force young members of
families to join their ranks.
They'll force women
to become sex slaves.
We call them
[SPEAKING SPANISH],, forced
girlfriends of gang members.
And so homicide, disappearances,
sexual violence all
become ways of exercising
control in these areas.
And the state is
incapable of stopping
that Incapable of holding
back criminal groups who
are capable of violating
fundamental rights of citizens.
And what they've done, the
states, is declare war on them.
And in this war the state
has militarized certain parts
of the country
and used primarily
repressive and military means
to try and reduce violence.
Abandoning the consequences
of that violence,
meaning that the entire
security approach
has been a militaristic one.
And there are no programs to
assist victims of violence.
So when families
do become victims
the justice system, the police,
the social security networks,
the women's
protection institutes,
the children
protection institutes
are unable to do
anything for them.
And so when we
try and understand
why Central Americans or people
from the Northern Triangle
leave the region, primarily
it's because of commissions
of violence by criminal groups,
gangs, death squads, narco
trafficking groups.
But also violence by
the state, the army,
the police in the context
of a war on gangs.
And then omissions, the
failure of the state
to do anything to guarantee
their lives, to assist victims.
And so our goal
as an organization
is to provide victims with
a safe space and services
to stabilize their lives.
And in that sense, it's a
very humanitarian mission
to try and save lives.
But also use that assistance to
help people to see themselves
as agents of change.
To try and change and challenge
the security strategy.
To try and build and strengthen
the national protection system
so that other families who
are in similar situations
won't suffer without
any recourse.
And so I left on
your rows a poster,
a little poster that we made
of a drawing and a poem.
And I wanted to share
this as a story with you
to highlight how
our programs work.
This drawing was made by a young
girl in one of our safe houses.
And this girl was a member
of a family of 30 people.
And this family lived
in an area controlled
by a gang on the outskirts of
the capital of El Salvador, San
Salvador.
And this gang came
one day to the family
and raped two of their members.
They gang raped two
members of this family
and told the family that if
they reported the crimes,
if they resisted the gang's
future demands that they
would all be killed.
And so when the family was
threatened and suffered
these acts of violence they
displaced to another community
in El Salvador.
And while they were in hiding
in a house in another place,
the military entered into
the community in an operation
with the police in
which they began
to detain many of the young
men in that community.
But they entered into the home
where this family was in hiding
and began to fire.
And they killed the
matriarch of the family.
And they told the family
members that if they
reported this crime,
if they said anything,
that they would all die.
And that's when they
entered into our program
where we were able to provide
safe house protection for them,
humanitarian assistance,
legal assistance,
psychosocial assistance, medical
assistance to try and stabilize
the family.
But in that process we
began to talk to them
about their rights, helping
them see that the violence
and displacement that they had
suffered isn't their fault.
That it's part of a system,
a security strategy that's
immanently violent.
But also part of a
structural problem
in which the state
or the society
hasn't made a commitment
to protecting and assisting
victims.
But that there's something
that could be done about that.
And we began to talk to them
about maybe reconsidering
reporting what happened.
And we mentioned
to them the option
of doing what we call
strategic litigation.
That in El Salvador there
is a special mechanism
that in the case of violation
of constitutional rights,
citizens can go directly to
the highest judicial authority,
the Supreme Court.
And we asked them
if they would be
willing to make a claim to
the Supreme Court holding
the Attorney General,
the Minister of Defense,
the Minister of
Justice and Security,
and the Salvadoran legislature
responsible for violating
their constitutional rights
in failing to protect them.
And they didn't really
even think about it
very long at all.
They said, we understand
what happened to us.
And if we can do anything
so that other families don't
suffer what we have,
then it's worth the risk
of trying to seek justice.
And so they gave our lawyers,
our legal team, legal powers.
And we presented a claim to
the Salvadoran Supreme Court
suing those people I
mentioned for violating
constitutional rights.
I know this sounds
a little bit boring.
But to make the
long story short,
on July 13th the Supreme
Court of El Salvador
ruled in favor of the victims.
They said that the
Salvadoran state
has to recognize internal
displacement by violence
and their responsibility
to protect victims.
They gave the state
six months to create
a legislative framework
to build policy proposals
and make a budget priority for
programs in the national budget
to assist victims.
And so we moved quickly
with the family.
They authorized
us to draft a law
and present it to the
Salvadoran legislature about two
weeks ago.
A special law to build a
national response to assist
internally displaced people.
And the law, when
we presented it
to the Security Committee
of the legislator,
the President took it directly
to the legislative assembly
and asked for a streamlined
legislative process.
And we needed 41 votes
for it to be admitted.
And we got 44 on
the first round.
And so now the law is being
assessed at the legal offices,
all the ministries.
And it's moving forward.
So we have this
unbelievable opportunity.
We're working with one case
with, as we said in the video,
with one family.
To safeguard their lives
we're now in a position
to design the first
national response
to internal displacement by
violence in Central America.
And that's in El
Salvador, but we
think that that model can
be used to also respond
in Guatemala and Honduras.
So it's a great privilege
of ours in the organization
to be able to work
directly with victims
and safeguarding their lives.
But also be a part of expanding
protection for human rights
to an entire
population of people.
And designing also the national
response to this great problem
affecting our region.
So that's a success story.
We're very happy.
The poem I wanted to
draw your attention to,
we translated at the
bottom of the poster.
The drawing, we debated
whether this was something
that's inspirational or not.
But in the end, I think
it's quite inspirational.
You can see in the
drawing that there's
a caged bird in the mouth of the
girl, something that reminds us
of the slogan that
many people see
on the walls in the communities.
It is see, here, and shut up.
That's how you stay safe.
And this is, as you can
imagine, a girl writing
in a clandestine safe house.
She writes this poem and
it is called "Sadness."
It says, "if I am
free, I will be happy.
I am the light that
illuminates in all places.
I am your refuge and
I am your happiness."
And I think the poem in
itself has its own merits.
But when I think of how the
courage of her and her family
in seeking justice and the
impact that potentially
could have on so many
other people and families,
I think that she's right.
That she is the light and the
refuge for many in her hope.
And if you like, you can
take these posters with you
to share the story
with other people.
I wanted to just
maybe close by sharing
a little bit of a
reflection that we've
been making about our work.
Kathy mentioned that part
of our commitment to working
with victims in Central
America has led us also
to representing the victims
of the El Mazote Massacre.
El Mazote is the
largest massacre
perpetrated in the Western
hemisphere in modern times.
In 1980, the Salvadoran
military entered
into the village of El
Mazote and slaughtered
over 1,000 people.
Most of them were children.
Today, Cristosal, as
a private plaintiff,
is prosecuting the
Minister of Defense
and the Salvadoran Military
High Command, the people who
were the architects of the war
strategy from 1980 to 1984.
And that war strategy was one
in which the military decided
to exterminate all people who
lived in areas where there was
a presence of insurgent groups.
And one of the
things that we talk
about when we talk about these
types of cases in which we're
trying war criminals, or
trying people for crimes
against humanity,
is that we don't
believe that in successfully
prosecuting this case
we will stop war crimes from
ever happening ever again.
But what we do think makes
this struggle worthwhile,
beyond the victim's right
to truth and justice,
is that we have the
opportunity to challenge
the assumption of impunity.
That is the idea
that powerful people
can do what they like
with weaker people
simply because they can.
And there will be no
consequences for it.
That's one of the
dynamics of dictatorship
and authoritarianism,
is this idea
that I can do what I like
simply because I'm powerful.
And I can do whatever I
like with whomever I like.
And when we look
at those patterns,
sometimes that impunity
manifests itself
in atrocities like the
El Mazote Massacre.
And sometimes it
manifests itself
in simple corruption,
the idea that because I'm
powerful I can do what I
like with the resources
of the state, for example.
And so this legacy in
Central America of violence,
of abandonment of the
victims, and of corruption
is linked to a historic
legacy of impunity.
And so when we are prosecuting
the war crimes committed
during the Salvadoran
Civil War 30 years ago,
we think there's a direct
connection with our work
with victims today.
And we also think
that there's something
important to be said in the
world about the assumption
of impunity.
When we look around
at our region,
and we look around
at the world, we
see a resurgence in
authoritarianism.
New governments
emerging or governments
transforming into increasingly
authoritarian regimes.
And we think that
sending a signal
through the successful
prosecution of one
of the largest
unprosecuted war crimes
will help us to challenge
that assumption of impunity.
To say that we can be
light, like the young girl
wrote, in the world
right now where
we see setbacks in many
protections of human rights.
We see setbacks in the
expansion of liberal democracy
around the world.
That we have to and we
have a responsibility
to continue to
challenge impunity.
Uphold standards
that we believe are
the basis for the foundation
of peace and security
in the world.
And those standards,
we believe those
to be that all people
are fundamentally
equal in rights and dignity.
And respect for
that principle is
the basis of peace and
security across the world.
I'm not making that up.
It's what the World
War II generation
signed into the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
The generation
that suffered some
of the worst atrocities
known in human history
concluded that our peace,
that peace in the world,
is linked to my
concern with how people
are treated in my own country.
But also how people are
treated in other countries.
And so I think I'll conclude
my remarks there and maybe
open it up to questions.
AUDIENCE: So that was
a lot of information.
What can we do here as people
that live here in the Bay Area?
What can we do to
help with this cause?
NOAH BULLOCK: Yeah, I have
given some thought to that
specifically in this
first opportunity
to be with you at
Google, because I
think there are some
specific things that you
could help us do.
In general, we need
people to give.
I think all NGOs need donors.
Our work as an independent
human rights organization
depends on people making gifts.
Unrestricted gifts that
allow us to work on
issues that other
people don't want.
And to begin to develop
programmatic responses
before big donors
are willing to.
So individuals like you
all who make gifts allow
us to do the things that we do.
Also, we need people
who help us to advocate,
who are willing to talk to their
friends about Central America,
about immigration, and even
about Cristosal's work.
And to help us
expand our network
of support in the Bay Area.
But more specifically
with Google,
there's something
that I think we can
continue in conversation about.
But NGOs, we don't
have tech budgets.
We don't have
technical expertise
to look at information
security, communications
plans and strategies and tools.
Any number of things like that
often become the last thing
that you do with the grant.
The last couple cents
in the grant, right.
And one of the things that
I am absolutely convinced of
is we have a series
of human rights tools.
I mentioned that we have
litigation and legal
assistance.
We have protection units.
We have research units.
These are all tools for
advocacy and assistance.
But one of the most
important tools right now,
especially in the advent of this
resurgence of authoritarianism,
is our ability to
influence public opinion.
The litigation or the
Supreme Court ruling
wouldn't have happened if
we wouldn't have first won
the national narrative
about displacement.
The government said
it doesn't exist
and that the victims are liars.
But the media believe our
statistics and our information.
And I think if you did a survey
of opinion and in El Salvador,
overwhelmingly people
would support our position
and the Supreme Court ruling.
But we don't have the tools
to do that so systematically.
I think as an
organization we need
to have more sophisticated
ways of assessing
current public opinion,
identifying sectors of support,
identifying the means
of communication,
and messages to effectively
influence public opinion.
That public opinion
and expectation
guarantees that a Supreme
Court ruling is implemented.
Or that a new law holds weight.
That becomes one of
those primary bulwarks
against the
assumption of impunity
that powerful groups
in the countries
can do whatever they want.
Because if they believe that the
citizenry will confront them,
they'll think twice.
NGOs, human rights
NGOs, it's like were
in the 1980s in terms of
communication strategies
and resources.
And I mentioned
information security.
We do the best we can.
But I'm sure you
all know a lot more.
So the third one is
something to explore.
How we can work more
closely with you
all who have skill sets that
we don't as human rights dorks,
right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question
about indirect support
to neighboring countries.
I hear that in Europe a lot of
politicians across the spectrum
are trying to shift the
narrative regarding migration
to advocate for supporting
countries in the region,
especially to reduce
economic migration.
And therefore shore up
the right of asylum.
So we hear politicians
in Scandinavia
who are pushing for
more support for Turkey.
Or to have richer countries like
Saudi Arabia taking refugees.
I'm wondering if you think
that the US can do anything
given that immigration to the US
is really sensitive to provide
better resources to Mexico,
Costa Rica, other countries
in that region.
Or if you think
that's an argument
to deflect
responsibility to states
that couldn't necessarily
handle the influx of refugees.
NOAH BULLOCK: The issue
that you're touching on
is called burden sharing.
It's established in the
1951 Refugee Convention
that no one state
should bear the burden
of all refugees in the world.
But the whole world
should bear that burden.
And I think in the world
the overwhelming majorities
of refugees are hosted by poor
and middle income countries.
And what I said at the outset
of my presentation here,
the United States is not
suffering an immigration crisis
or a refugee crisis numerically.
And Europe really isn't either.
The largest numbers are in poor
and middle income countries.
And so how do we
respond collectively
to build capacity but
also share burden?
And the way that the
international community
is doing that is
through what they
call a Global
Compact on refugees,
but through new strategies to
externalize responsibility.
So for example,
the United States
supports Mexico with the
Southern Border Plan.
It's this idea of extending
the border to the south
to stop migrants
before they come,
which can be seen as
a way of cutting off
traditional access which
is at the border to refugee
protection.
There's a whole series of
actions, like you mentioned,
that are trying to find ways
to skirt shared responsibility
directly.
And that tendency
also confronts what
is the distinction between
a migrant and a refugee.
Because what refugees are
doing around the world,
they're behaving differently
than they used to.
We have a refugee crisis because
the international community is
incapable of ending conflict.
So all conflicts keep going on.
And new conflicts
become protracted.
And so you have an accumulation
of displaced people.
And the world is unable to
supply the humanitarian needs
of those growing populations.
And so what refugees are
doing is they're not--
like in El Salvador
in the 1980s,
many refugees crossed the
border and into Honduras
and waited in refugee camps
for the conflict to end.
And when it ended they returned.
Today where refugees
are doing is,
I'm not going to sit
around in a refugee camp
and wait for them
to give me food
because I don't think this
thing is ever going to end.
And even if it
did, I don't think
I'll be safe in my country.
And so they enter into
a migratory routes.
We call that mixed flows.
And so the whole world is
trying to figure out who's
a refugee, who's a migrant.
What are the responsibilities?
If one is a refugee
and one is a migrant,
then it's all very complicated.
The largest emerging
displacement crisis
in the world is Venezuela.
Possibly by next
year there'll be
more people displaced
in Venezuela
or something similar to
what you have in Syria.
But there's no armed
conflict in Venezuela.
And so all of the
countries in South America
are saying we have a bunch
of Venezuelan migrants.
We don't have refugees here.
So there's sort of
a crisis, and we
don't know how to
interpret what's happening.
We're skirting
responsibilities collectively.
And instead of trying to assume
responsibilities and generate
a comprehensive humanitarian
response to displacement,
end conflict, we're trying
to skirt responsibilities
and externalize it to
countries of origin or host
countries of refugees.
Having said that, I
also think, for example,
the bilateral support of
the United States government
to the three countries
in the Northern Triangle
to build protection
responses is important.
I'll be in Washington
DC in October.
And I'm going to take
the Supreme Court ruling
and I'm going to
say to Congress,
this is a roadmap for response.
Support it.
So I think that we have to
play both roles, assuming
the responsibilities at home,
treating people with dignity
and respect independent
of their condition.
But also have solidarity
with countries of origin
as they try and transform
those root causes.
That was a long answer
to your question.
But I could actually just
go on and on about it
because it's the major
contentious issue
in international
relations right now.
It's just a big, big topic.
AUDIENCE: I have a couple.
Just to get back to your
specific example, so
what was the outcome
for the family?
NOAH BULLOCK: Yeah,
they left the country.
All of them have
left the country
and are in the process
of refugee resettlement
somewhere else in the world.
The last member to
leave the country
was the father, the patriarch.
And he stayed in the
country long enough
to give testimony at
the Supreme Court.
And it was a
powerful experience.
Because it's not normal
for the Supreme Court
to ask for those sort of
first-hand testimonies.
And we did a lot of
witness prep with him
prior to his interrogation
at the Court.
And the guy, he did numbers.
He did the numbers
about how much
is in the security
budget of El Salvador.
And he said, we as citizens
are paying all this money
into security.
And look, my whole
family is dead.
I lost my house.
I lost my livelihood.
I lost my wife.
So they owe me all
that money back.
And we talked to him
about that not necessarily
being the approach
that we should
take in the Supreme Court.
But he did an amazing job.
You can imagine that there were
15 defense lawyers representing
the highest officials in
the Salvadoran government.
And his testimony,
he said, I was
displaced by gangs at first.
And when we sought help from
the government there was none.
And I lost my home.
I lost 25 years of mortgage.
I lost my business.
My family was dispersed.
We lost all of our belongings.
And then once we were in hiding
and hoping to find protection,
and he turned and
looked directly
at the defense attorney
for the Minister of Justice
and Security and he
said, you killed my wife.
And so it was a pretty
powerful moment.
The Magistrates of the
Court, in open court
recognizing executional
killings and procedural fraud
in investigations
and serious issues.
But he had the courage to do it.
And when he was done,
we interviewed him
and asked him how he
felt. And he just started
crying tears of happiness.
Something similar happens
with war crimes trials.
When the survivors have given
testimony in court for so long,
society has told them that
what happened to them is either
their fault, they're criminals,
or it just didn't happen.
And when they're able to
tell their story in front
of the judicial authorities,
it's an important reparation
to have society acknowledge
the terrible things
that have happened to
you and acknowledge
that those aren't
your fault. That's
what happened to the family.
AUDIENCE: Through your process
of one case, one family,
one individual at a time, how
many cases, families, have
Cristosal worked with and
helped in the period you've
been with them?
NOAH BULLOCK: Well, I can
remember case number one.
Our first case-- we detected
this problem of displacement
because we were
administering the High
Commissioner for Refugees
program in El Salvador.
So our mandate was
to assist people
from other countries seeking
asylum in El Salvador, which
were very few people.
And Salvadorans began
to come to our office
and trying to request asylum
which you can't do until you
leave the country, right.
But we got so many cases that we
decided that we should probably
close this one
program down and begin
to think about how we might
assist Salvadorans fleeing
violence in the country.
And we began to talk
around and trying
to do advocacy
internally in the country
and also externally
about the issue.
But there was really
no context for anyone
to understand it until the
child migrant crisis in 2014.
But what I wanted
to say about that
is that our first case was
a family of 25 people who
were forced to flee
their homes and ended up
camping outside the US embassy.
When we heard about
that I said, oh man.
We have to put our money
where our mouth is.
And we had been planning
on building our protection
responses and safe houses
and things like that.
But we had no resources yet.
We weren't ready for it.
And I said to my
program director
the embassy is going to call
us before 10:00 in the morning.
I'm sure of it.
So basically the
first case I spent
the payroll for the
next month to try
and activate our
first safe house.
Literally from our
accountants all the way to
are our tiny legal staff--
we were an organization
of eight people at that point.
We all took turns
operating the safe house.
And that was case one.
And now were on
case 450 something.
So we've assisted thousands
of individual people.
And now we're operating
in Guatemala and Honduras
and beginning to see some of
the first results of our work
there as well.
This was case 91.
AUDIENCE: One other question.
The human rights-based approach
that Cristosal has adopted,
can you explain that a little
bit in three or four minutes?
NOAH BULLOCK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And where
the genesis of it,
and how you're playing it?
NOAH BULLOCK: Yeah,
I've used words
that evoke a rights-based
approach, accountability,
responsibility, the state.
After World War II, the
international human rights
resume was set up.
It was set up on the basis
of a nation-state system.
And the idea is
that a nation-state
is the primary guarantor
of human rights,
but also the primary
violator of human rights.
And that means that it's
crime until the state fails
to respond in a systematic way.
And then it becomes
human rights violation.
A murder is a murder.
But the state's responsible for
investigating and prosecuting
and protecting.
States have to prevent, repair,
protect citizens, right.
That's what they do.
And so a rights-based
approach is this idea
that there are people
who have rights.
But then there are also
organizations and people
who have corresponding duties.
And so when we look at a problem
from a rights-based approach,
we can't as an organization
substitute the people who have
rights--
in the case of the
victims, them-- and their
processes of seeking justice.
And we can't substitute the
state in their responsibilities
to fulfill rights.
So our actions have
to be empowering
of both those parties.
Meaning we have to empower the
victims to activate justice,
to hold duty bearers or
the state accountable.
But also we have to find
ways of strengthening
the capacity of the
state to fulfill
through positive actions.
Like for example, in
El Salvador we just
open a joint safe house with the
Women's Development Institute.
And we're transferring
our knowledge and models
of protecting families
to a state actor.
But also, we have to
hold them accountable
for systematic situations
of discrimination
through actions like litigation.
So what we can't do is
enter into the country
and begin to substitute the
state by only assisting.
That's the responsibility
of the state.
What we're trying
to do is demonstrate
how that could be done and then
activating the state to do it.
So what's actually
worked out really strange
with this whole case
of the litigation
is through legal action
we created an obligation,
a clear one on the state.
Through the presentation
of new legislation,
we've designed a
national response
and organized how
the state is supposed
to be responsible to victims.
And in developing legal
models of assistance,
humanitarian assistance,
psychosocial assistance we
also can show the state
how they will respond.
That's a rights-based approach.
We've been able to assist
now thousands of people.
But in doing that,
we've also demonstrated
how nationally the
government could respond
and created an
obligation to do it.
It's a different way of working
than limiting your access
to humanitarian assistance.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
ensure that as you're
going through the
process you are working
not only with victims
and with the state,
but also with diverse voices
who come from within the state
and externally to create
a pathway for the state
to operate with victims?
NOAH BULLOCK: Yeah, you
can't only confront.
You can't just be
confrontational, right.
Otherwise you're
just on the outside
screaming towards those
who hold power, right.
You have to find
entry points and begin
to work also cooperatively.
So we've done that in
all three countries.
In El Salvador, the
human rights ombudsman,
which is a national
office for human rights,
recognized forced displacement
I think about four years ago
in a partnership
agreement with Cristosal.
And we did assessments
with how they
assist and drafted new
protocols and helped
them to begin to respond.
So they were the first state
institution to respond.
And we've done that with the
public defender's office,
with the Women's
Development Institute.
We're working on that with
the Ministry of Health.
So you have to find allies.
The state is a big thing.
It's not monolithic.
And so you have to work
both that side, that more
confrontation or
litigation side,
to keep an obligation going.
But also to work
cooperatively to show how
response and strength and
capacities for fulfillment.
So you're right that there
has to be that balance.
And that means you
have to navigate
tricky political
alliances sometimes.
John, maybe one last thing.
Before you leave, I just want to
call your attention to just one
photo here.
This one at the bottom, that's
a photo from the courtroom
in Morazan where we're
prosecuting El Mozote war crime
trial.
In this day, this woman Rosario
was giving her testimony.
She's a survivor
of the massacre.
And this guy right here with
the gray hair and the glasses
was responsible for the
Salvadorian Armed Forces
in 1980.
And he had to present
himself in court that day.
And you can see this look
that she's giving him.
I think that's another
example of the light, right.
It's a really powerful
photo because she
has had to wait 30 years
to be able to confront.
Thank you, all.
[APPLAUSE]